The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
So today, what I
want to do is, as requested
and promised last week,
today we'll spend some time just
reviewing some of the things
we've talked about up until
now and some of the concepts
that you might find
questions around on the quiz.
So maybe I'll ask you guys,
just to make sure you understand
each of the key concepts.
I'll also, as part
of this review,
we'll look at a
couple of questions,
a couple more questions,
from last year, from the quiz
last year.
You have a practice
quiz and in solutions,
and that would be a
good idea to look at.
Those are posted on
Stellar, as well.
That's not to say that
that's exactly what you're
going to get.
But you might get-- in terms
of topics, those are good ones.
But what's not on
the practice quiz
is sort of any pictures of a
density of states or a band
structure.
I can almost
guarantee you you'll
have sort of one of each
of those on the real quiz.
So you'll have a band
structure that I'll
ask you some questions
about, as well as a DOS plot.
So we're sort of
supposed to be here.
And I still hope to
get to solar cells.
And we have time, so we're
going to talk about solar cells.
But I know that, since
the quiz is Thursday,
we want to take a
good chunk of today
and just make sure that we
have a good sense of what
to expect and do a review.
But I hope to get
to our beginning
of talking about modeling
solar cells today, as well.
And we'll pick up on
that after the quiz.
Are there any questions
just about the quiz, which
is Thursday?
It's open book, open
notes, no phones, PDAs.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How many
questions can we expect?
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Somewhere--
definitely no more
than 100, and--
[LAUGHS] I'm kidding.
10-- I don't know.
Does that sound about
right, something like that?
12.
OK, so there we are.
Now, I do want to,
since Lynn already
made a little
announcement about part 2,
I wanted to start today--
so that's what
we're going to do.
I wanted to just, even though
I just postponed the piece
that-- oh, I'm going to have an
office hour tomorrow at 4:00.
Is that what I
said, 4:00 to 5:00?
Or did I say 5:00 to 6:00?
4:00 to 5:00, I think.
But if anybody has questions,
as always, send me an email.
And I'm happy to answer
electronically or set up
a time to meet that
works on your side.
So that's very good.
And how many of you have
looked at problem 3?
A couple of you, OK.
So are there any questions
that anybody has about problem
3 right now who
have looked at it?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Well, in terms of--
how do you find
maximum efficiency?
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
All right, [LAUGHS]
that's a good question.
That's a really good question.
Anything more specific?
AUDIENCE: You know
the maximum efficiency
is going to be related
to the energy going
in versus going out.
But how do you determine, I
guess, the energy going out?
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah.
Yeah.
OK, so let me talk a little bit
about this problem to make sure
that we kind of know
where to go with it.
And the key setup here
is actually really
part A, in a way.
It seems pretty simple.
But it's kind of the
core piece of information
that you need to understand.
And I'm going to use
this yellow chalk that's
actually white to draw.
Let's not forget what it is
that we're talking about,
which is basically
an energy landscape.
Remember, in capturing
the sun's energy,
what we're trying to--
what we're doing--
and in many energy
technologies, what we're doing
is we're pumping something
up an energy hill.
And in this case,
we pump an electron.
We shine light on it.
And the molecule is
in the trans state.
And then it gets excited
because the light, the electrons
from the photons from
the light, excite
electrons in the molecule.
So that's that pumping
action that's happening.
You're pumping electrons
within this molecule
up to a higher level.
When you do that,
the molecule is
allowed to go to here just from
that energy from the light.
So the light's energy
is being converted
into creating electrons
that are higher in energy.
And that allows the molecule
to go from this structure
to this structure.
And that's allowing you
to store this much energy.
So don't forget this picture as
you think about this homework,
because this homework is
all about this picture.
Now, who can tell me-- we
talked about this in class
already when we talked about
this whole solar thermal fuel
concept.
Who can tell me why--
who can tell me the
answer to part A?
Let's just see if we
can do that together.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is it because
there's a energy [INAUDIBLE]
between the trans and
the cis states that's
higher than natural cis energy?
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
OK, so here I'm going.
I'm shining light, and I
shined light of this energy--
or if you want to
think about it as HC
over lambda of that
amount of energy,
just going between
wavelength and frequency.
And I shined light
on this trans state,
and I only shined light
with this amount of energy.
Can it possibly be
converted to here?
It can't, because we can't--
now, some of you
took 3.012, and you
know we don't violate the
laws of thermodynamics.
Those are untouchable.
You can't get something
for nothing, right?
So you're not going to get to
store this much energy if you
only put in this much.
That kind of makes sense.
You can't put it
up on some shelf
of energy, some
chemical shelf, which
is a way of thinking about
this, if you haven't given
it enough to get up there--
unless you use a lot of thermal
vibrations, but that's not what
we're doing here.
You could use heat.
But you can't get it with
this input less than output.
OK, so that's sort of
what part A is asking.
Does everybody see that?
Now, here comes the fun part.
But, you see, it's not just--
this is the molecule sort
of going about its business.
This is the
happy-go-lucky molecule.
But then we have the sun.
We have this part.
Where does this come from?
Well, this is the sun, you see.
And that has its
thing that it does.
And its thing that it does
is it has intensity that
comes in as a function of--
this has probably nothing
to do with the real curve,
but I draw the sun's intensity
different every time I draw it.
But this would be, say--
well, this could be energy
or wavelength or frequency.
Let's call it energy.
And so you have a dependence of
intensity of the sunlight that
strikes the Earth
or the atmosphere--
those are different--
on the energy that you get.
So there's some
energies of light
that have a lot of intensity
and some that have very little.
Now, what's the key connection
here between these two?
Who remembers?
Which is really what
part 2 is about,
question 2 is about-- what's
the key connection here
between this curve
and this picture?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So only photons
with a sufficient energy
will be able to excite your
molecule from the trans
to cis states.
So only some part of
that curve with energy
greater than or equal to delta
H will be able to do that.
So it can only capture that
much of the sun's total energy?
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Yeah, exactly.
And there's something else, too.
But that's exactly what
we need for a problem 3.
That's exactly it.
So what I've told you--
what we did already
is we said, well,
you can't get more energy
out than you put in.
So you've got to
have at least delta
H. Minimum of sun's
energy is delta H. That's
the absolute minimum you have
to put into this to get delta H
stored, right?
Sorry, that's kind
of hard to read.
I'm not liking this
yellow-colored white chalk,
because it's too thick.
So the minimum sun's energy is--
that's better-- is delta H.
But you see, there's also
now-- what happens is--
so let's say I can--
let's say that delta
is somewhere here.
I don't know.
Call it one electron volt. well,
what I've just said in part A
is that anything below that,
anything below one electron
volt, cannot be used
to store energy.
So any sunlight energy
that's below that is wasted.
It's not going to do
anything to charge that fuel,
because it's below this amount.
On the other hand,
everything above that
will charge the fuel.
But now here's where the
question of efficiency
comes in, because is it really--
what would I really
like to do here
in terms of charging this fuel?
Somebody tell me the difference
between a photon of sunlight
energy that's here,
that charges the fuel,
versus one that's out here
that also charges the fuel.
Somebody tell me what's
different or similar
between those two parts of
the spectrum, both of which
convert my fuel.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The one that's higher
energy has less energy wasted,
because delta H is constant.
So once you get above it,
the more above it you get,
the less efficient it becomes.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Exactly.
Exactly.
So I can charge the fuel
now because, I said,
I can't have less than
how much I'm storing.
That's a rule but
I can charge you
with anything above that
except for one thing
that I'm going to tell
you about in a second.
Or you're going to
tell me, because I
know somebody knows this.
But if I use this amount
of energy from the sun,
well, I still only stored that.
That's my delta H. So that
means I wasted a whole lot.
And that's what I
want you to tell me.
What's the efficiency?
So if I'm all the way down
here, you can say, well--
and this is what we talked
about in the lecture.
If I'm all the way
down here, then I
can absorb all this light
and use it to convert.
But light up here
is really wasted.
It's super wasted the
further you get up in energy.
So where is the sweet spot?
There's going to
be a sweet spot.
That's what I want you
to tell me in part B, OK?
Now, there's something
I'm not telling you
which is really
important here that's not
part of that question.
But there's something
else that matters
a lot that's part of part B--
number 2, question number 2.
What have we not considered yet?
And in particular,
what about it?
AUDIENCE: Gap.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
The band gap.
The gap, or the gap
of the molecule--
and you see, because that's
the other component here.
So these are--
problem 3 is talking
about theoretical limits based
on how much the molecule stores
and how much sunlight
shines on it.
But there's this other thing
that problem 2 talks about,
which is the fact that the
molecule will not absorb
any light lower than its gap.
And that's why
those two problems
are very I think
complementary to one another.
So all of that comes into play.
So even if I say,
well, it stores in EV,
so theoretically, it
could absorb all of this.
Actually, if its gap is 2
EV, it's only absorbing this.
But we're not talking about the
gap in problem number 2, OK?
All right.
It's fun.
This is fun, right?
Any questions?
We're integrating the sun.
Any questions
about that problem?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So to find the
energy that's lost, do we just
have to subtract the
delta H energy from all
of the high-energy states
and integrate that new area?
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah,
it seems to me like--
so you figured out in
the earlier problem
how to figure out that,
if you integrated this,
you would get, like, how
much of the sun's energy
that molecule is absorbing.
And you used the band
gap as the cutoff.
But now it seems
like maybe you want
to use delta H in a
similar way, because you're
looking at sort of a
theoretical efficiency
and ignoring the gap.
Now, then, what
is the efficiency?
Well, it's how much
energy that molecule
can take in from the sun--
divided by that, the
amount that is stored.
Did I answer your question,
or did I dance around it?
Was that helpful?
AUDIENCE: How do
you, like, physically
calculate that amount?
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Ah, but
that's what you-- you chose it.
You just picked it.
You said, I'm going
to say it stores 1 EV,
because that was delta H.
AUDIENCE: But if there's
one of these per--
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Per molecule.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Per molecule
is the way to think
about it, right?
And then there's-- so that's
how much energy you're storing
in each molecule, and then each
molecule is getting how much
energy from the sun?
Right?
And between those, you
have an efficiency.
It's basically 1
divided by the other.
And you know which one
to divide by the other,
because if you divide it,
and it's more than one,
you should do it the other way.
That's a hint.
No, but seriously, are there--
did that make sense enough?
OK.
Now, question C
is a little bit--
taking that a
little bit further.
But it's that same
exact concept that--
yeah, OK.
Any questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I'm just
a little confused.
So when we calculate
the band gap,
that's the amount of
energy needed for it
to absorb energy from the sun.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Right.
AUDIENCE: Then how does
that relate to the delta H?
Are those separate?
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah,
that's a great, great question.
And that really is--
I want you to think about them
separately for this problem.
So they really are,
of course, intertwined
in fairly complicated ways.
But here, what I
want you to do is
suppose you could
just make the gap.
At any delta H, you could
just make it equal to delta H.
That's really what
you're doing here,
because you're taking a
kind of theoretical limit
exercise in this.
That's not the case.
It's not as tunable as that.
Although, you can tune
the gap in these materials
to quite an extent.
But here I'm saying, suppose
that the amount it absorbs
is, in fact, set not by the gap
but by this other constraint
that is part A of
this question, which
is that you just can't
convert it unless you
have as much as delta H.
That's just-- that
there's no way around.
You can't tune around that.
That's just it.
You can't get to here unless
enough energy from the sun
is this or more.
So that's really
ignoring the gap.
But in reality, it's going
to only absorb photons
at the gap or higher.
But if you found it--
now, if you were to
happen to do 3B and get
a maximum in a
curve, let's suppose,
and that maximum occurred
at a certain delta H,
then you might say, well,
that's where I should try
to get my gap to that point.
That might be some guidance.
Of course, that's not
actually what you want to do.
But as we ignore the gap, you
can think about it that way.
It provides some guidance
into where you might look at--
these kinds of exercises
in theoretical efficiencies
can always be useful
for those reasons.
Does that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: I think so.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Definitely, I'm
very happy to talk
about this more.
Office hours, tomorrow at
4:00 and also by request--
so just send me an email.
Or if you-- I think a lot of you
know, if you send me an email,
I'll try to write
back pretty quickly.
So if you have questions,
I'm happy to answer.
Are we feeling good?
Yeah.
OK.
Nope, we're not going to look
at a recommendation letter
together.
[LAUGHTER] That
wouldn't be appropriate.
[LAUGHS] Wait a second.
But there was-- yeah, let's
get that out of there.
And there was a--
aha, here we go.
What did you do?
Now, this is not
this year's quiz.
But this is last year's quiz.
And I'll do this first,
because then we can review.
So here's a couple of questions
from last year's quiz.
Let's just focus on this one.
Oh, what are basis
functions, and how
do if you have enough of them.
Somebody answer
that for me first.
What are basis functions, and
how do if you have Enough yeah
AUDIENCE: So basis
functions are a set
of functions which you
can take combinations
of to create an approximation of
what the exact function should
be.
And you know you
have enough of them
if whatever you're
trying to calculate
you use basis set and then a,
I guess, more refined basis
and do this a little bit.
And it sort of
converges to some value.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Right.
Exactly.
There's a really
important part of that.
So that is-- basis functions
are mathematical functions--
Gaussians, exponents,
plane waves, wavelets.
Don't use wavelets.
But they're kind of funny.
They're neat functions.
But it can be anything.
It's just a function.
And you just use them.
You use a series of them
usually, a sequence of them
that you add together, to
make up the complexity that
is psi, which is
the wave function,
the wave function that
we're after in this part
of the course.
So it's just a
representation, but it's one
that you don't find in
classical simulations
that you did in the first part.
But you do find it here.
And it's really important to
know when you're converged.
And say that part again.
When are you converged?
AUDIENCE: When you use --
when you take whatever
you're trying to calculate--
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Ah, stop right there.
That's it-- whatever
you're trying to calculate.
What are you trying
to calculate?
Give me an example.
AUDIENCE: Total
energy of a system.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Total
energy of the system.
Now give me another example.
AUDIENCE: HOMO-LUMO gap.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
HOMO-LUMO gap.
I love it.
We could go on like
this, but I won't.
But now, are the number
of basis functions
you need to converge the
representation of your wave
function the same for the total
energy or the HOMO-LUMO gap?
AUDIENCE: No.
AUDIENCE: Depends.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: It depends
is always a good answer.
You can always write that.
Don't put it for your name,
but you can put it for--
well, I don't know.
Maybe you do need the
same number of functions
for those properties.
But you need to look at them on
a property-by-property basis,
no pun intended.
OK?
So very good.
Now, without solving any
equations, which electron
do you think would require more
basis functions to describe
well the 2p electron in carbon
or the 3p electron in silicon?
Who can tell me what they think?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: 3p
electron in silicon.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Well,
you need-- now, hang on.
You need more basis
functions for 3p?
Tell me why.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
more electron attraction.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Well, what is
it that makes you need
more basis functions?
What is it that makes you
need more basis functions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It's like a more
complex wave function.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
OK, so if the function--
if the wave function looks
like this versus, say,
a wave function that
looks like that,
which one do you think I'm going
to need more functions for?
I'm going to need more basis
functions for this one.
Does everybody see that?
Now, and then the question is,
OK, so if you put that down,
you're already
doing really well,
because on these questions, what
I'm looking for isn't even--
if you didn't know the answer
to what 2p carbon or 3p silicon,
which one is more wiggly,
but you knew that you needed
to know that to answer the
question, that's already--
that's, in my opinion,
4 out of 5 points,
because that's the key.
The key is what--
I'm trying to just get
at the key things you
need to know in computational
quantum mechanics, some
of the key ingredients.
And that's the key is
that you need more basis
functions if the
electrons function wiggles
more or wiggles more quickly.
AUDIENCE: But it's [INAUDIBLE].
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
What was more for carbon?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Because the--
you see, it's what
you said, actually.
You have more
screening in silicon.
And so the outer electrons,
they're further out,
and they actually wiggle less.
They're more smooth.
That's not always true.
But between silicon and
carbon, that's true.
I think I talked about
that in lecture 2.
And it's part of why carbon
can make such strong bonds.
So carbon has no p
electrons in the core.
Silicon does.
So the screening
is very different.
A p electron in carbon sees
no p electrons in the core.
But a p electron
in silicon does.
It sees two p
electrons in the core.
So that screening,
that shielding,
makes a huge difference
in the kind of bonding
that these two atoms can do.
That's why we're made of
carbon and not silicon.
But that's not the question.
Now let's do another one.
Materials are composed
of nuclei and electrons.
When the Kohn-Sham
equation is solved,
solutions only for
electrons are obtained.
Why do we not care about nuclei?
Come on, that's a
good one, right?
Sam?
AUDIENCE: So basically,
nuclei are 1,000 times heavier
than electrons.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Right.
AUDIENCE: But
realistically, electrons
are basically still
[INAUDIBLE] motions in saying
that electrons are [INAUDIBLE].
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: And do you
remember what that's called?
It's that guy's
back, the tattoo.
AUDIENCE: Born-Oppenheimer.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Born-Oppenheimer.
See, that's going to be it.
You're always going to remember
that guy's tattoo on his back,
and you're going to
think Born-Oppenheimer.
It's effective.
OK, and then we'll do one more.
What does k-point
sampling refer to?
Below are the band
structures computed
for two different materials.
Which requires more
k-points to converge?
And what I'm looking for
here is not a long essay.
It's really just a sentence
to explain the reasoning.
So somebody tell me which of
these might need more k-points.
Which band structure
would need more k-points?
I see this.
Yes, why?
AUDIENCE: There's
more variation.
There's more wiggles with
it, so you need more points
to get after [INAUDIBLE].
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: It's the
same-- you see, these are--
this is also just a
convergence question, OK?
Did everybody see that?
This is another
convergence question.
I mean, you're not going to
just get convergence questions,
but those two were.
And then we did this one.
Did everybody see
this last time?
OK.
This is that band
structure that you got,
but your advisor
spilled coffee on it,
and this is the
only copy you have.
And so I'm not-- you won't
have a coffee-spilled-- well,
you might have a
coffee-spilled band structure,
because it's kind of a
fun way to ask questions.
But you'll definitely have a
question about band structures.
So make sure you kind of are
comfortable with the concepts
that I'm going to--
we'll review right now
with band structures.
So those are a couple of
nice examples of the kinds
of problems you might get.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, you can see a
coffee stain in the example.
Don't [INAUDIBLE] because
[INAUDIBLE] put in there.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah,
we're going to actually
use real coffee this time.
[LAUGHTER] OK, good.
So what we're going to do now--
so any questions?
The questions are great.
It's really helpful-- questions
on the p set, questions
on those questions?
Questions on the questions?
Questions about--
AUDIENCE: The Celtics.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
What was that?
The Celtics?
They're going to wrap it up.
Yeah, tonight.
Anyway, OK-- I just like sharing
a little something like this
each time.
Has everybody seen this one?
With great power comes
great responsibility.
Vision without
action is a dream.
Action without vision
is a nightmare.
This is my reminder.
When you do calculations,
this is what counts most.
don't just start computing.
Think about what you're doing.
I'm going to take you through
a little bit of a tour of some
of the key concepts
that I think would
be important to know about that
you might get questions on.
You might get a question on--
and I think there's a
practice quiz question or two
on some of these--
concepts of what led to quantum
mechanics, which we talked
about in the first lecture.
So why did we need
a new physics?
Why did we need something new?
And the fact that you have--
as a result of a lot of research
in that time, what came out
of it was that matter has both
wave and particle character.
So we've talked about
this experiment.
We've talked about
that experiment.
So you would know if
I asked a question
about those experiments,
maybe, one of them.
And we found that
that, actually, light
can behave like a particle, and
matter can behave like a wave.
And it would have
a wave vector k
that's related to its
momentum and a frequency.
And that's kind of really cool.
So if I asked you what the
wavelength of a baseball was--
I think that might have
been on the practice quiz--
then that's something you
could compute, for example.
I won't ask you
that, but you kind of
could compute the
wavelength of something.
And then that took us to--
well, OK, so you have
to represent matter now
with waves.
So we're going to have
this function to do that.
So that took us
to this function.
We said there's going
to be this function.
It's a wave function.
Well, that's a creative name.
It's a function that
represents waves.
OK, that's good.
And we also said--
we didn't really explain
this much, but we said,
but you can't--
we don't actually know much
about the physical meaning
of this function.
But we do know that,
when you square it,
or since it's complex,
you multiply it
by its complex
conjugate, that you
get the density of this
quantum mechanical particle.
And we said, this is it.
This is what we need.
We need this function,
because in quantum mechanics,
that function tells you
where electrons are,
the probability
density of electrons.
And so that's the thing we need.
Because if you
know that, then you
get all these other
properties, see?
Once you have this, that's
what the DOS comes from.
That's what the band
structure comes from.
It came from solving for that.
And then the question is,
well, what are you solving?
And so what we needed
there was the F
equals MA of quantum mechanics.
We needed the equation
that governs the behavior
of this wave function.
And that's the
Schrodinger equation.
That's it.
This is it, right?
So do we have the
function that we need,
which when we solve it, we
get all these properties
that we really
care about, that we
can use to make solar
cells and solar fuels
and lots of other things?
There is an equation
we need to solve
to get that wave function,
and that equation
is the Schrodinger equation.
And we took time out,
because we don't like time.
It just complicates things.
And so we did it for
the stationary solution.
And the Schrodinger equation
is H psi equals E psi,
where H is the total energy.
So it's the kinetic energy
plus the potential energy.
And when you write
these out, you
write out the kinetic energy
as this second derivative.
And the potential--
well, that depends
on what we're talking about.
But if we're talking about, say,
an electron in a hydrogen atom,
then it's E squared over r.
That's your potential,
the potential that that
charged particle feels.
So that's a hydrogen atom.
That's the electron
in a hydrogen atom.
I'm going through this quickly,
because I think we are all
feeling OK about this.
But if anyone has questions,
please raise your hand, please,
because if you have a
question, it's very likely
someone else has
the same question.
Any questions?
Now, you can solve this
equation, actually,
very easily.
We did this, I think, in
the second lecture, maybe.
And you get solutions
for that wave function.
And we talked about how
one of the key results
here is that you
get quantization
of the energies of
the wave function.
And what that means is
that the energies can only
have certain values--
nothing in between.
And we talked about
the magic of that
and how that explains
these spectral lines that
were observed long before.
It finally explained those.
So I don't know like calculating
the energy differences here
or how much energy it takes
to allow electrons to move
from one level to another--
that sounds like a
good problem to me.
and units, so forth.
Now, the other
piece of ingredient
that was really important is
that, actually, electrons--
they have this angular
moment-- they have this spin.
And it was observed
by putting them--
shooting them through a big
magnet and basically finding
that--
what was observed?
What was observed wasn't
just that they had spin
but that they only had
one of two kinds of spin.
So instead of
getting a spread, you
would think you
would be applying
a force on these electrons,
which are magnetic,
since they're spinning.
But they're not.
But that's how we like to think
of them in our classical minds.
You would think
that you would get
a nice continuous spread of
force acting on them, causing
them to separate.
But instead, you
only get two spots.
That was really important,
because they told us
that these there's another kind
of quantum mechanical number,
which is the spin number,
which can be up or down--
only up or down.
And then you put that
together, and you put together
your solution for the
Schrodinger equation,
and voila.
You get, essentially-- oh, you
add on a little bit of Pauli.
You put in some
Pauli exclusions--
just a little bit.
You don't want to over-Pauli--
anyway, never mind.
Which it says that, OK, we
got these quantum numbers--
you know, N, L, M,
and now the spin.
And no two electrons
can have the same set,
which results in the fact that
you cannot put more than two
electrons in one of
these energy levels.
And remember,
these energy levels
are kind of like
the key ingredient
we're after in this class.
It's really one of
the key ingredients
we're after, where do those
electrons want to sit,
because it tells us so much
about properties of materials
that are interesting.
Now, that really allows
you to go to a description
of the whole periodic table.
The problem is that that
was a description based
on one electron and one proton.
We solve for that.
We could solve for that.
And so we did, and
we got the levels,
and that was really neat.
And then we had rules
about how to fill them,
and that was really neat.
And then you can
actually explain
a lot of chemistry that way.
You get your S and your
P and your D orbitals,
and you fill them.
The problem is
that, actually, when
you have anything
but hydrogen, you
have more than one electron.
and so that really requires
going back to the Schrodinger
equation and adding in the
interactions between electrons
that was not in the
original hydrogen atom.
And that's hard.
That's the hard
part, hard stuff.
And so we turn to computation.
That's really hard
to do analytically,
and it gets much, much worse
the more electrons you have.
any questions up to this point?
All right.
So how do we do that?
Well, you've got to-- so
we're using computation,
but you can't just
throw this onto a grid
or throw this into MATLAB.
It still isn't doable.
And so there's sort
of two branches
in computational quantum
mechanics, one that loosely
is labeled quantum chemistry
and the other kind of more
solid-state physics,
density functional theory.
And both of them
make approximations.
And we talked about
those approximations.
And what they're approximating
is the Schrodinger equation.
They're simplifying
it, because even as
simple as that may look--
just throw that into MATLAB--
it doesn't happen.
You can't solve it when
you have more than a couple
of electrons--
five electrons, I
don't know, six.
That won't be on the quiz.
[LAUGHS]
But you just can't solve
it exactly on a computer
unless you have the
age of the universe.
And even then, it's too hard.
So we've got to
simplify this equation.
And mostly in the quantum
chemistry world, what you do
is you simplify this.
We talked about using
basis sets, basis functions
to represent this.
Well, you can restrict
the degrees of freedom
in that function, as well.
And that makes that
equation much easier.
And the other thing you can do
is you can actually change--
so that's changing this
part, and the other thing
is you could change this part.
And that's what physicists
mostly did, and now everyone
holds hands and sings
"Kumbaya," and everyone's happy.
Back then, there was
a lot of two fields,
physicists versus
chemists, and all that.
But we're all
happy together now.
So chemists do density
functional theory.
Physicists don't mind wave
function-based methods,
as they're called.
The result-- and this
was one of my red flag
key results here
is that what you've
done when you do this is you
have taken a problem that
involved all of these
interactions-- remember,
1 over r 1, 2 meant
taking into account
the interaction between
electron 1 and electron 2.
And that just gets
really painful and hard.
And so what you've
done in both categories
is you've completely changed
the picture into what's
called a mean field picture.
So each electron is
only now really solved
in the context of an average
field of the other electrons.
That's the simplification key.
That's the key simplification.
So the mean field
methods are really
what enable us to do
computational quantum
mechanics for large systems.
I don't really think
I need to review this
too much, because I did
just review this, I think,
a week ago.
But the density is a
nice thing to work with,
because unlike the function with
sort of-- if you wanted a grid
to represent each--
a grid of points, even as the
number of atoms in the system
grows, the density
grid is just the same.
So the number of points you
need to represent the density
is constant, while
the number of points
you would need to represent
psi grows exponentially.
So it's a really hard problem
in the context of scaling
with size for the wave
function, but the density
offers this really nice scaling.
And so that's what density
functional theory is
is it's a method that relates--
it shows that the density can
be related to the wave function.
And then you just
work with the density,
and you throw out
the wave function.
You bring it back in
later, but that's basically
what the theory does.
The problem is that
it pushes out--
it has this sort of term that
you talked about in lecture 3
or 4 that you have to kind
of approximate, this exchange
correlation potential.
We talked about that.
And the exchange correlation
potential-- let's get to that--
is not known.
If you knew it, it would be,
actually, an exact method.
But it's not, and so
you make approximations.
And these are actually
two of the approximations
that you have as options
in the NanoLab tools.
Now, what these approximations
are is not part of this class.
That gets into kind of
more complicated equations
that we would have to cover
that I don't want to do.
But what I want you
to pull out from this
is that we are not solving the
Schrodinger equation exactly.
We are making approximations.
And those approximations
need to be checked.
So you see, there's two
kinds of convergence here.
That's the key, right?
And this is where I come
with responsibility.
One kind of convergence
is k-points, basis sets.
But another kind of
convergence is, where are you
in accuracy space?
Where are you?
Do you know?
Because you are
making approximations.
When you pull down that
option on the toolkit
to say GGA or LDA, what
you're doing is you're
changing the form of this.
Which one is right?
You're still not solving
the equations exactly.
So how do if you're right?
Throw that out
there as a question.
AUDIENCE: Find an
experimentalist.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Find an experimentalist.
Bother them.
Say, can you measure this?
And they say, no, are you crazy?
My advisor just told me
to work 90 hours a week
on something else.
So then what do you do, because
it's not in the literature?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Try a bunch of
different approximations
and see if any of them agree.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: See
if any of them agree.
Let's suppose half of them
agree, and half of them
disagree.
Say I had 10 functionals
to choose from.
What else could you do?
Or are you done?
Is that good enough?
AUDIENCE: Maybe run one more.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Run one more.
AUDIENCE: The tiebreaker.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
The tiebreaker--
I love it.
[LAUGHTER]
Sadly, there are papers in
the literature that kind of
take that approach.
It's a little too loosey-goosey.
But it was a good idea.
OK, what else?
Well, is it good enough?
I mean, if I had
10 functionals--
by the way, there are
hundreds of functionals
now to choose from in
density functional theory.
If I had 10, and
half of them agreed,
but the other half
didn't, what do I do?
AUDIENCE: Apply
quantum chemistry.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: OK, why?
AUDIENCE: It's a whole
different theory.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Whole
different theory-- good, OK.
Go to a different theory
for quantum mechanics.
See what that agrees with.
But see, that may
have its own whole--
it does have its own whole
world of approximations.
But that's the right--
that's sort of the right way to
think about it, because there
are theories that are
more accurate and less
accurate in how they solve for--
how they simplify the
Schrodinger equation.
So you can try to go to
more accurate, or what
are known to be better
accurate, theories.
Now, there's one
other thing to do.
I told you that, in
this particular case,
it's a solar fuel that
you just calculated.
You think it's going
to be revolutionary
but only by one functional.
The other functional
says it's really bad.
You went to an experimentalist.
They said no.
And you can't do
higher-level theory.
Anything else you can do?
AUDIENCE: Take a poll?
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Take a poll
[LAUGHS] of your group members?
[LAUGHS] That's good.
I like that-- computational
people, people computing.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Request more funding.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
What is that?
AUDIENCE: I said,
request more funding.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Request more funding--
you're talking like a professor.
[LAUGHTER]
What else?
Anything else?
There is something
else you can do.
So the key is--
I said that the experiment for
that fuel hasn't been done.
But--
AUDIENCE: Try a different fuel.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: OK.
Use the same level
theory on a system
that has been done
that's related,
that's closely related.
While I modified azobenzenes
and make a good fuel,
that hasn't been made yet.
But azobenzene has.
Did my theory work well
for all of the data
I can get my hands on
that's relevant to what I'm
simulating for that material?
This is validation.
It's not the same
as convergence.
I said there's sort of
two kinds of convergence.
This kind is called
validation, and it
is critical in computation.
It is a critical
part of computation.
Please don't go
away from this class
without remembering that part.
Know where you are.
Test your calculations.
Be confident in them
because you validated them.
Too much computation goes
on that doesn't have that,
and it's a lot of wasted time--
[LAUGHS] computer time,
but also people time.
Now, so we can get
a lot of properties.
We can get properties of--
I've talked about lots
of different properties
you can get.
I won't ask you anything on
the test about properties
we haven't actually really
talked about in class, OK?
But you can calculate
a lot of things.
We just talked about this.
The one thing-- OK, did you
exit the scf at the right loop?
Don't worry about that, because
the code just sort of does
that for you.
Was my basis big enough?
We talked about that, right?
Convergence for molecules--
was my box big enough?
Now, why do I have
a box for molecules?
What does that even mean?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So you're going to use
plane waves as your basic set,
and they're periodic.
And a real molecule's
not going to be periodic.
So you don't want to
have it see itself.
So you need a really big box.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
So if I have--
so a lot of these codes,
especially plane-wave codes,
were originally
developed for solids.
But they work fine
for molecules.
Actually SIESTA's not
even a plane-wave code.
It uses a different
kind of basis.
It uses a more Gaussian-like,
localized functions basis.
But it's still a periodic box.
It's based on a periodic box.
So that means that when you
input something like an atom,
if I want to simulate
that one atom, then
I need to make sure that I leave
enough space so that it's not
going to feel its periodic
image in all directions.
So for a new molecule, is my
box big enough means leaving
vacuum between the molecules.
And then we talked about solids.
And that's certainly
fair game for the quiz,
even though we
haven't had a homework
problem on the solar
cells, certainly I
wouldn't talk about that.
I won't talk about
solar cells on the quiz.
Or I should rephrase that.
[LAUGHS] I won't
ask you questions
that we haven't talked
about in lecture.
But the band structure
of a solar cell-- well,
band structures we've
talked about a lot, right?
Now, the way we built
up our solids part
is we said, well,
OK, now we're talking
not about some molecule
that can have some shape
and then gets
repeated like this.
But we're actually talking
now about a crystal
that goes on forever and ever.
And so it needs to
have a kind of lattice.
And we talked about how
you can define that,
just like we
defined it in class,
and you've seen it
in other classes.
You define it in a computer.
And then we talked about
the inverse lattice,
and I'm not going to
go through this again.
But we built this up.
Why did we build up
the inverse lattice,
the understanding of that?
Where does that come in?
Why do you need to know
about inverse lattice?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Because
that's how we define
the Brillouin zone,
which is where
we define the k-space vectors.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Good.
OK, and why does k-space matter?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
associated with [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Yeah, so that's exactly--
the inverse lattice is
the reciprocal lattice
of our real lattice.
It's really important
in crystallography,
so I think a lot of
you have seen this.
And you can define by just
drawing these perpendiculars
to the nearest neighbors you
defined the first Brillouin
zone, which is where the energy
levels, those precious energy
levels of this
molecule that I want--
that first Brillouin zone is
where in the inverse lattice--
see, this now becomes inverse
space, also known as k-space.
That becomes a
degree of freedom.
And so that makes
these guys move.
They can even move
and cross one another.
And that is the
difference between
a solid computational quantum
mechanics on a solid--
what you can get
out in a molecule.
And the Brillouin
zone is the playground
of this space that matters.
Because as we showed
from Bloch's theorem,
if you go outside of
the Brillouin zone,
you can just wrap it and get
back exactly to where you work.
So your function and your
energies won't change.
So all that matters is to know
and understand and compute,
which is what the code does, the
variation inside this Brillouin
zone.
That's why we defined
it, because we just
don't need any other zone.
And we got here by looking
at periodic potential,
and the result of solving
the Schrodinger equation
in the presence of
a periodic potential
is that you get this new
constraint on the wave
function.
And the key here is that--
OK, so this is just saying you
can go one lattice vector away
and get back to same thing.
That's why I just said about
only the Brillouin zone
mattering.
But the key result of
Bloch's theorem is not here.
Ha.
But the key results
of Bloch's theorem
is that you have this
k in the first place.
The key result is that
you have a new index.
Just like the quantum numbers
came out of the hydrogen atom,
you have a new
index that can vary.
And as it varies, it
changes your levels.
And we spent some time
talking about this.
So please let me know if you
have any questions about this.
I just talked
right into the mic.
[LAUGHS] (LOUDER) Let me know
if you have any-- oh, sorry.
[LAUGHS] Does everybody
understand that?
By putting-- by mapping
quantum mechanics and all
of our machinery,
Schrodinger equation,
approximations to it--
but remember, H
psi equals E psi.
H has v.
And by having v be the
same everywhere in space,
we got this new
degree of freedom,
this new thing that's critical.
And this new thing is what
makes a band structure.
So if I showed you a
band structure like this,
what am I simulating?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
What is that?
Forget these other ones.
Just look at those.
AUDIENCE: It's a molecule.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah, it's
a non-periodic system, right?
If the bands are flat, you don't
have this variation in k-space.
And if you don't have
the variation in k-space,
well, at least to within
what the system can feel,
it's not a crystal.
It's not a periodically
repeating potential.
It may be, or it
may be really close.
What if you had a molecular
crystal, which exist?
There are many
molecular crystals.
But they're really
far spaced apart.
These molecules are
weakly interacting.
Well, you might get,
then, something-- you
might just start to see
this-- and we've played
with this in the computer.
You might just start to
see some little wiggles,
feeling that effective
the variation in k-space.
But you won't see very much.
And then as the interactions,
or as the potential
that's periodic, gets stronger,
well, then this variation
can get very high.
Any questions about any of that?
So that's kind of
the key point there.
And we talked about the
kinds of things you can get.
And we also talked about how--
so this is density
functional theory.
We talked about how, when you
solve for the band structure,
you first converge the density.
That's a separate calculation.
And then what am I doing here?
How do I get this?
The third point
is sort of silly.
You plot.
But point 2, what am I doing?
Somebody explain point 2.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You go in
the Brillouin zone,
and you look at the
different points in k-space.
And then, using
those points, you
define potential for band gaps.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah.
Well, you find-- yeah,
you find the band gaps.
You find the energy
levels at each point.
But as we said,
as you just said,
you're doing this for lines
in the Brillouin zone.
How do you choose which lines?
AUDIENCE: Your choice.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: My choice--
but I need to choose.
Sam?
AUDIENCE: You pick the
high-symmetry region.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah, it's
the high-symmetry parts, right?
We talked about that.
Because why?
AUDIENCE: Nature
likes symmetries.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Well,
that's a good answer.
[LAUGHS] That's
always a good answer.
Nature does like symmetry.
It's a beautiful thing.
But is that really
why that's what
I do for my band structure?
What does that mean?
AUDIENCE: After reaction
occurs, [INAUDIBLE]..
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Pretty much.
That's where the variation
that could happen in the energy
levels is going to happen.
And that's what you
want to capture, right?
So a band structure is a
simple two-dimensional way
of cruising through this kind
of complex three-dimensional
Brillouin zone where things
are varying any point I go.
But if I go just along
the high-symmetry points,
then I get the variation
that's usually most important.
And then we talked about
how you fill these up
to the Fermi energy.
Is the for energy always at 0?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: No.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah.
So if I didn't tell you where
the Fermi energy is, and I
asked you to tell me if it's
a metal or an insulator,
could you?
Would it even be possible?
Why or why not?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Because then
we'd see whether or not
the bands are constant, right?
And if they're constant, then we
know it's going to [INAUDIBLE]..
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Yeah, and so
if I leave that
piece of information
out, which I did last
year, and I give you
a band structure
that looks like this,
and then let's say you
have bands up here,
well, everybody
is really excited
to call this an insulator.
I'm excited to do it.
I can hardly hold back.
This is an insulator.
But hang on.
If I didn't tell you where
the Fermi energy is, what
if the Fermi energy is here?
You got to have
all the information
to answer the questions, right?
So know what
information you need
if you're asked a question
about a metal insulator.
And you know-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: Why do we typically
begin with the energy at 0?
What would be a case
where we vary it?
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: It's
only because it's sort of a--
there's no good reason
except that it's convenient.
AUDIENCE: OK, so usually
it's just static?
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: It's just
nice to shift them so they're
always at the same place.
And then we can compare
things more easily.
Why is this definitely going
to be a metal if I have
an odd number of electrons?
OK, there's a little
discussion there.
I want to know what
you guys are saying.
AUDIENCE: Confirming.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Confirming, OK.
You're validating-- I love
it-- using the group consensus.
Crowdsourcing is very powerful.
Anyway, don't use
it for computing.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] if there's
not enough electrons, then
a band's only half filled.
The Fermi energy has
to be in that band.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Why?
That's exactly right.
Why?
AUDIENCE: The Fermi energy is
where you fill up until it's--
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: That's it.
Did everybody get that?
Fermi energy is the energy
that you fill the electrons to.
So if you have an odd
number of electrons, well,
how many electrons go in
each one of these bands?
AUDIENCE: Two.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Two.
So if I have an odd number
of electrons, one of them
is only going to be half filled.
That means my Fermi
energy has to cut it.
It's got to cut it
somewhere, which
means I have a band crossing
the Fermi energy, which
means it's a metal--
has to be.
You can think about
the same for an atom,
except that atoms are metals.
But most atoms have that case.
They have half or
partially filled levels.
You don't fill all the
p electrons in carbon
but we don't think of the
carbon atom as a metal,
because atoms and
molecules don't really
have this kind of behavior.
But it's the same idea.
You're partially filling levels.
We talked about-- how
are we feeling about
direct versus indirect gaps?
Good?
OK, we talked about that.
Yeah, liking that-- that
could be a good question.
And we talked about other
things that you can calculate--
vibrational properties.
We did talk about
magnetization, right?
Now, this is not--
sorry, this is actually from a
different code we used to use.
So just ignore this.
We used to use a different
code than SIESTA.
And that was the input for it.
And this is showing that
you can do calculations
of, say, different phases of
a magnetic material like iron.
And how would I calculate
the magnetization
of those materials?
This was in lecture something,
some number of days ago.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I guess you could put
on and apply the magnetic field
and then see where
[INAUDIBLE] is.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
You absolutely could,
and that would be really hard.
But you could do that, actually.
And we do do that.
But that's a hard calculation.
What is the magnetization of
material what's it due to,
anyway?
What part of the
materials is due to?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: A difference
in density and space
between the spin
up and spin down.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah.
Yeah, it's due to electrons.
It's due to the spin
of the electrons.
That's what gave us the
Stern-Gerlach experiments.
It was the
magnetization possible
of the spins of the electrons.
It was the fact that
a magnetic field
could exert a force on those.
Now, we said that,
in your material,
you have spin up
electrons and spin down
electrons, the precious
things that were computing
this whole second half.
And you fill those up.
And you fill them up.
According to the Pauli
exclusion principle,
you fill the levels up with
these electrons, right?
But when you get to a
solid or, even in atoms,
you don't always
necessarily have
the same up and down electrons.
You can have differences.
And when you have
differences between them,
you can have a net
magnetic moment.
And we talked about that before.
And then we said, well,
OK, if I had an atom,
then you can have a
net magnetic moment.
Just count the number of up
electrons minus the number
of down electrons.
But in a solid, in
a crystal, you now
have these electrons
in these bands.
You need to use something else.
And that's where you need to
use the density of states.
And so if you have sort
of the density of states--
now, remember--
versus, say, energy,
and this is something
you're all now
familiar with from the homework,
but we talked about this, also,
how it relates to magnetism,
and that, in the SIESTA tool,
you could plot, for example,
the spin up electrons.
So let's say these are
And then you can plot
the spin down electrons.
And that's a little hard
to see because there's
three curves with one color.
But the main point is that the
up electrons and down electrons
could be very
different in where they
are in energy, which translates
into what where the peaks are
in the DOS.
Now, you see, what
matters, though,
is not the difference
across the whole DOS curve.
What's going to matter?
It's not the whole
DOS that matters.
It's only part of it.
Which part?
Yeah, it's the part up
until the Fermi level.
What are the differences in
where I filled electrons?
Between the ones
that would be up
and the ones that
would be down, right?
Now, and that got us to talking
about this spin-polarized thing
that we talked about last time.
And that's a little button
on your simulation tool
that you can check or uncheck.
So if something
is spin-polarized,
it allows the up and down
electrons to be different,
to have different energies.
So I just I just told
you that difference is
what gives you magnetization.
So if you don't allow
it to be spin-polarized,
then you won't get
magnetization, right?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Isn't there
a spin up and spin
down electron in every energy
state [INAUDIBLE] that are all
going to have the same energy?
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Ah, very good question--
and that is exactly what
spin-polarized does.
You see, so this is what
you're talking about.
You're saying, well, isn't
this just in one level?
But it actually, it
turns out, that that's
what's called a restricted--
you can say restricted
closed shell
or restricted open shell--
formalism that is valid
for many, many materials
and molecules, where in
fact, there's no difference.
But in reality-- in reality--
even when it's
restricted, you still
should write these as a sort of
one spin channel and another.
You could call it alpha is spin
up, and beta is is spin down.
And each one of
those has its own set
of orbitals and wave functions.
So in reality, that's
what you solve for.
Now, in many materials,
it turns out alpha
and beta electrons do have
the exact same energy level,
but not always.
And actually, in exactly
what you were talking about,
when I apply a
magnetic field even
to a material that's
not very magnetic,
you can cause big
shifts in these.
You can-- depends.
That depends on the material.
But when you apply external
perturbations to the system,
you can split these
so that actually you
do have this picture where the
energy of the spin up channel
for that energy level is
different than the spin
down channel.
And that's exactly what
spin-polarized does.
It allows those energies
to be different.
Without that, you can't really
study magnetism correctly.
That's a good question.
OK, and so we talked
about some other things.
We did talk about how you
could calculate electrical
conductivity-- so
that's fair game--
from the band structure.
There's an equation in the
lecture from last week on that.
We didn't talk about
thermal conductivity.
We've talked about optical
properties and magnetization.
That looks like
it's just repeating
the first and fourth bullet,
which is interesting to me.
But these are the
kinds of things
we can calculate using the band
structure in the DOS, which
is what we've focused on
a lot in the last three,
four lectures.
So that's certainly I would
think you should know about,
how to get some of
the key properties
from the band structure in
DOS in these first four,
excluding thermal, which
we didn't talk about.
And with the
convergence questions,
we got to have a
convergence question, right?
You just-- you got to.
You would feel cheated if
you didn't have one, right?
And I don't want you
to have that feeling.
When you have a
solid, k-points now
becomes a convergence parameter.
So that's kind of our review.
Any questions?
Any questions about that at all?
Any thoughts or comments?
Any other questions?
We're good?
Any questions about the quiz?
OK, let me just take five
minutes to do a little stuff,
get it out of the way,
so that after the quiz
we can dive into--
or do you guys just
kind of want to--
maybe we stop here, huh?
Should we stop here?
Except five minutes on
solar right before quiz.
Yeah.
I'll tell you what--
I'll do my little energy slides,
and then we'll start solar.
Because this isn't really
solar, but it's related.
And I don't think I
showed these before.
Did I show these
before when I was
motivating research and energy?
I really like this.
We talk a lot about
global warming.
And I think that's a
really important topic.
And there's some really great
work and, unfortunately,
not enough understanding,
I think, on--
[LAUGHS] I don't even
know where to begin.
You know the polls show
that half of this country
still doesn't think that
there's any evidence that it's
anthropogenically linked.
But anyway-- OK, so let's
say we don't talk about that.
And we ignore these sort of
really hard scientific facts.
There are other reasons
other reasons to think
about renewable energy.
And I like this one.
I don't know how many of you
have seen something like this,
but this is-- the United
Nations puts this out.
This is the Human
Development Index.
What's that Mean I
feel pretty developed.
I mean, does that just
mean I can go to Starbucks
and get a latte when I want?
No, this means health
care, education.
It means I can read.
It means I could maybe have
a light on at night to read.
But it's primarily some
sort of key indices
that talk about sort of
the well-being of a person.
And that, you can see, is
incredibly strongly correlated
with how much energy
a country gets.
So this is the amount of
per-capita electricity use.
And that's this Human
Development-- it's basically
a well-being index.
As you can see, some people get
surprised that Canada beats us.
So how do they beat us?
AUDIENCE: It's cold.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: It's cold.
It's really cold
up there, right?
But you can just see
the strong correlation.
The question is, when they--
see, there's enough
fossil fuels for everybody
here, probably, certainly
if you go with coal.
There's a whole lot of
energy in fossil fuels,
and we could lift a lot of
these people up the curve.
The question is, is that
really how we want to do it?
Now, the other point
I want to make--
and this will be the
other intro point.
Just so you have
in your minds when
you're talking to
people about energy,
it's not just about
global warming.
And this was a great experiment
that was run accidentally
when 256 power
plants went offline
in the Eastern corridor.
This is one of these stories
where one plant goes off
because a mouse chewed
through a wire or something,
and then the whole
country feels it.
But it was a great
test bed, because they
were offline for quite a lot.
All these things shut down.
Everything had to shut down.
And so people took
planes up and did testing
and published these
results of the air quality.
And it's incredible
to look at the data.
You look at all
kinds of stuff that
affect what we breathe,
what we see, how we live,
who has asthma.
A lot of that stuff
goes down instantly.
So there are different reasons
than just global warming.
And I like this map.
I don't know if I
showed this to you.
But this is how much we
consume scaled by consumption.
This is the country,
the world map.
[LAUGHTER]
We're pretty big-- pretty big.
There are some places
that are pretty small.
OK, so you scale it by country.
I mean, one question
that comes up and gets
modified is, how much energy
do we really need, or power?
In 2002, we burned energy at
a rate of 3 and 1/2 terawatts.
What's it going to be in 2050?
Well, if you make
some assumptions
about how many people there are,
and if everybody used energy
like us, which is
really inefficiently,
then we need 100
terawatts in 2050.
We only have 13 now, 14 now.
We need a whole lot.
And we like to think that people
are going to be more efficient,
and so that becomes the target--
30 terawatts, 30 to 50 terawatts
is what we're going to need.
How do we generate that?
Well, this is-- and
this is all just, again,
building up to solar, which
we'll start next week.
This is how we've
generated it so far.
We burned a lot of wood,
and that was kind of dirty.
So we burned coal, and
that was really dirty.
But there's so much
coal, and it's so cheap.
[LAUGHTER]
And then we found oil, which
is this magnificent energy
carrier.
It's a solar resource.
All these are solar resources,
by the way, including hydro.
Now, natural gas,
with fracking-- this
is going to go-- from this
it's going to go like this
and just sort of
take over this chart.
Fracking in the last few
years has done more for energy
than anything has
in many decades.
But that's not that's not
what I'm talking about.
I'm talking about
this green sliver,
which is where I like to sit.
And we separate out hydro,
because at least on-shore hydro
is fairly tapped out.
And then you've got
that green sliver.
And the thing is that, if
you look at global warming
curves, CO2
emissions, people talk
about wanting half
of all the energy
to come from that
green sliver by 2050.
So you back the numbers out.
We need 30 terawatts in 2050.
That's how much the world needs
if we're really good at how we
use it, 100 if we're like us.
And you want half of that to
come from a green sliver, which
isn't really expanding much.
And notice, it's sitting
on a slope like this.
This slope is still--
could go even much
higher much faster.
This is a really tall challenge.
This is the challenge that
I like to think about,
is how can we actually do that.
And solar PV, I think, is--
and I'll end on this
side, and so we'll
start we'll pick up from
here on the technology part
and the science part next week.
We use about 15 terawatts today.
Does anybody know how
much we get from the sun?
I think I did talk about that.
What's the number
we get from the sun?
We use 15 terawatts a year.
How much do we get
from the sun per year?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
40,000-- roughly 40,000.
There's just is a whole lot of
energy that comes with the sun.
The energy released
by an earthquake
we get from the sun in a second.
You probably heard this.
Every year, we get
that amount of energy
in an hour from the sun.
Here's what I like--
you may not have heard.
The total resource
of oil, including
the 2 trillion
barrels we've used,
roughly, and the trillion
more that we're going to use,
for sure--
that amount of
energy resource you
get from the sun in two days.
It's an incredible
resource, right?
But apart from just
painting a barrel black
and heating water with it,
we really don't use it much.
And even there, we don't
use it much at all.
Solar photovoltaics is an
extremely appealing way
of trying to capture
this resource
and really change
that green sliver.
And so that's what I
want to talk about next,
after the quiz.
OK, so see you all Thursday,
office hours tomorrow.
Any questions at all,
please send me an email.